vai mostrar como é que nós podemos
produzir o órgão mais complexo e
prefeito que existe um universo
o cérebro humano serra mínima tem um
kiwi maio mas no seu interior um tempo
fascinante mundo são 86 bilhões de
neurônios dos neurônios quantas estrelas
existe na nossa galáxia messier ônibus
comigo todos entre si
são mais de 175 mil quilômetros de fios
ligação num total de 10 triliões se
natos para processar todos os
pensamentos emoções de da isso o cérebro
consome aproximadamente 20% da nossa
energia corporal
apesar de ser movido apenas 20 volte a
usar todos nós chegamos com esse
magnífico órgão dentro do nosso cérebro
é extremamente frágil e não existe essa
substituição será o inverso e o
investimento nessa muito mais cheia do
que vocês imaginam a partir dos 20 anos
de idade
começamos a perder funções cognitivas e
maioria destas começa a cair a partir da
terceira ou quarta década de vida
não são apenas os seus objectivos que
mudam o declínio é também em termos de
estrutura o cérebro diminui o volume à
medida que o tempo passa e algumas
estruturas cerebrais chegam é perder
cerca de 30 é 40% da massa cerebral
original
obviamente que quando perdemos demasiado
é massa cerebral começam a surgir
doenças incluindo cognitivo pode acabar
nas meias por exemplo será o zagueiro
começou a usar meia hoje em dia
um grande problema de saúde pública só
tem tendência a piorar porque o número
de idosos táxi exponencialmente o fruto
de um aumento da longevidade
assim a queda é de 3 segundos faça um
novo diagnóstico de uma doença de
alzheimer eo número de doentes com
doença de alzheimer tenda duplicar a
cada 20 anos
mesmo o cérebro não são só as doenças
cerebrais audiências um certo em outros
tipo de doenças têm doenças mentais
as doenças mentais hoje em dia são entre
todas as doenças que afetam a humanidade
aquelas que mais impacto tem no
indivíduo
estou também muito freqüentes neste
momento uma em cada 15 pessoas no mundo
sofre pressão e quatro em cada 15 se
juntarmos a adopção a cidade e estou só
a falar de duas das doenças mentais
agora nós temos que ver como é que nós
podemos evitar isso o único objectivo é
perceber a complexidade dessa questão
nós vamos pensar que existem fatores que
predispõem ao investimento os fatores de
risco é que o hospital o envelhecimento
cognitivo e fatores que protegem que
evitam esse declínio
obviamente que existem variáveis nós não
podemos mudar como por exemplo a nossa
genética alguns nascem com 200 mas
outros nem por isso
mas existe um conjunto de variáveis nós
ensinamos variáveis ambientais que têm a
ver com os tios de vida
nós hoje em dia sabemos que por exemplo
a baixa escolaridade ou tabagismo são
fatores que predispõem a envelhecimento
cerebral enquanto outras variáveis como
por exemplo o treino cognitivo hoje
atende técnica por tese o nosso cérebro
mas existe um fator que não está aqui
pesado e tem uma capacidade incrível de
produzir o nosso cérebro
esse fator
é um exercício físico e é sobre isso que
eu vim falar normalmente associamos o
exercício físico é uma melhoria mudanças
corporais ou seja nós fazemos exercício
eo movimento melhoramos a nossa
tunisinos cloro
melhoramos a nossa capacidade aeróbia
respiratória é nossa capacidade
cardiovascular
mas será que existe tráfico e exercício
físico tem consequências também em nível
cerebral
percebemos isso primeiro temos que saber
coisas isso físico por uns algumas
mudanças suazo se vocês quiserem
assistir físico ocorrem pequenos
processos como por exemplo uma redução
do stress oxidativo a uma diminuição da
libertação do cortisol que era uma
stress fazer exercício aumenta é a
produção ea libertação de
neurotransmissores como a dopamina ea
serotonina é aumentar a liberação de
endorfinas promove a formação de novos
vasos sanguíneos mas com as suas
consequências cerebrais destes pequenos
processo aço se é que existem o que é
espantoso é que o cérebro mulher com
exercício físico é que vocês vêem aqui é
comparação entre dois grupos entre um
grupo que faz exercício e um grupo de
pessoas sedentárias e encarnava estão
aquelas ondas cerebrais que tem maior
volume no grupo de pessoas que faz
exercício físico ou seja o exercício
físico está associado a um aumento do
volume cerebral
nós hoje em dia temos vindo é finnar um
pouco o que sabemos sobre essa sessão
entre exercício físico e cérebro
sabemos hoje em dia existe uma relação
linear entre exercício físico e volume
cerebral ou seja quanto mais exercício
nós fazemos mais cresce o nosso cérebro
e oposto também é verdadeiro
quanto mais tentarem somos por exemplo
quanto mais olhos nós vemos isto visão
mais baixo é o nosso conhecimento
inteligência concessão se vocês virem
ter toques em que a relação é inversa
obviamente e ultimamente temos vindo é
saber um pouco mais sobre essa relação
entre cérebro e exercícios sabemos hoje
em dia qual é um exercício que mais traz
benefícios em termos cerebrais quando
compararam o exercício aeróbio como
correr ou nadar com exercício de carga
como é que nós fazemos quando ginásio eo
exercício aeróbio que está mais
associado a alterações estruturais e do
funcionamento do cérebro
obviamente o passo seguinte é perceber
se nós conseguimos mudar o nosso cérebro
introduzindo exercício físico na que os
que nunca fizeram
e hoje em dia um conjunto de ensaios
clínicos está exatamente a fazer isso
numa um conjunto vasto de diferentes
patologias cerebrais por aqui é um
estudo no ensino de 20 pessoas adultos
em que foram divididos em dois grupos
num grupo fez durante um ano fez
exercício físico
e o outro foi pedido simplesmente que
fizesse alongamentos
o que é incrível é que na que o grupo
fez exercício físico o cérebro aumentou
o volume reverteu o investimento é de
aproximadamente r 1 e 2 anos enquanto
que o grupo só fez alongamentos teve uma
queda natural é associada o investimento
mas não foi uma zona qualquer que
aumenta o volume foi o hipocampo o
hipocampo é é a zona do cérebro
responsável pela memória de curto prazo
e longo prazo e também uma das poucas
zonas do cérebro onde ocorre um fenômeno
festineto que a produção de novos
neurônios que é neurogênese movimento
que o próximo passo foi pensar bem se
calhar é isso que nós estamos a ver é
simplesmente um artefacto
nada disso é verdade
isso é simplesmente o resultado
diferenças entre a nossa genética ou
provavelmente temos feito mais ou menos
16 quando éramos jovens
um grupo de investigadores na finlândia
do volta esta questão estudando gémeos
verdadeiros partilhavam exatamente o
mesmo material genético mas não
procuraram quaisquer gémeos verdadeiros
nos procuraram gêmeos com críticas muito
especiais eram para os emmys jovens
entre os 25 internos que tenham crescido
juntos tenham vivido juntos tinham
partilhado o mesmo teto o mesmo tempo
alimentação e tenham tenham tido os
mesmos hábitos dizer-se físico mas teve
uma diferença e os procuraram gêmeos já
não moravam juntos e que tenham livros
gelo no seu padrão de exercício físico
um dos gêmeos tenha continuado a
praticar exercício físico regularmente
enquanto o outro gêmeo tenha se tornado
sedentário
obviamente encontrar gêmeos assim em que
normalmente partilham tudo por
extremamente difícil encontrar um
disparo na finlândia e fizeram uma
ressonância magnética
olharam para servir aos e o que vocês
vêem aqui é comparação entre os
parceiros que fazem exercício e que deus
que se tornaram sedentários
o que é incrível é que os gêmeos
continuar a fazer exercício tenha um
cérebro melhor com mais volume do
comparar qualquer os inventários ou seja
apesar de partilharmos a mesma genética
e é mesmo é educação alimentação nós
conseguimos enganar a genética onde
conseguimos modificar o nosso cérebro
pergunta seguinte tem a ver com o fato
de se o que nós fazemos agora tem
consequências a longo prazo
isso pra mim sempre foi a grande notícia
do exercício físico
passamos meses sem necessitar de ir ao
ginásio e correr ganha música pra ver
peso aumentar a nossa capacidade cada
vez clara pois passou o verão passado um
ou dois meses
já temos outra vez mais gordos só temos
outra vez mais cansados ou seja tudo que
fizemos
converteu num prazo temporal muito curto
será que passa o mesmo serve para tudo
isto eu demonstrei passado um ou dois
meses volta atrás
para responder essa pergunta você tem
que falar do maior estudo jamais feito
ensina o flamengo está de framingham é
uma pequena cidade localizada nos
estados unidos da américa e foi
escolhida por isso mesmo processo por
ser uma cidade atípica perto de boston
completamente indistinguível de milhares
de outras cidades sustentáveis pelos
estados unidos em 1948 investigadores do
national institute of health que é
melhor agência governamental responsável
por toda a investigação a medicina foram
esse navio e selecionaram é
obrigatoriamente 5.000 hebe tanta
necessidade de submeter uma bateria
teste é cada dois anos os investigadores
voltam esta cidade e voltam a estudar
estes mesmos habitantes neste momento já
estão a estudar os netos da amostra
inicial mas recentemente com esta
tudo que nós tivemos o risco
cardiovascular vai investir tudo de
origem é mais de mil artigos científicos
os investigadores nesta última eleição
se irão explorar a relação entre corpo e
cérebro e para isso além de bateria de
exames que normalmente fazem viram os
habitantes para também fazerem uma
ressonância magnética que era se o nosso
a nossa forma física poderia ter
consequências cerebrais décadas pois é
isso compararam a forma física de há 20
anos atrás com as imagens cerebrais
obtidas atualmente o que uns encontraram
por incrível que pareça foi que forma
física da 20 anos atrás estava associava
e
dia o funcionamento cerebral atual
mostrando que o que vocês fazem termos
exercício tem consequências a nível do
funcionamento cerebral
décadas mais tarde é que os que há 20
anos atrás tinham 20% é baixo da forma
física eram aqueles que hoje em dia
tinham em média 1 é mais em termos de
envelhecimento cerebral há muito uma
última questão que eu gostava de lhes
mostrar e que nos deve passar a todos
pela cabeça
será que os a votar pra começar a fazer
exercício e ter algum ganho responder
esta pergunta esta esta questão eu não
vou falar do estudo
vamos contar uma história a história de
uma mulher vestida é em 1919 chamava o
record theo
olga foi a sua vida toda
professora do ensino secundário ela
durante a sua vida
o unix por fez ocasionalmente foi jogar
softbol uma forma muito light dois
golpes por popular no país onde ela
viveu foi o caneira pois a forma óbvia
decidiu começar a fazer atletismo
aos 37 anos é óbvia treinava
regularmente com o treinador contratou
até três horas por dia e cônsul é
participar em campeonatos é poroso
provas foi a campeonatos do mundo e foi
acumulando vitórias e recordes tem 37
recordes do mundo do atletismo tão
variadas como o lançamento do peso
lançamento de dardo o lançamento do
disco os 100 metros 200 metros o salto
em altura e salto em comprimento
continha 92 anos
investigadores da universidade é que eu
não quero é nadar seguiram se a mala por
criança estudar o cérebro delas o céu
infelizmente não têm outras pessoas
quando venta anos saudáveis com o qual
pudessem comparar o cerro droga então
compararam com mulheres 20 anos mais
jovem
entre os 60 e os 80 anos e o que
observar um foi notável em termos de
memória e função cognitiva o cérebro
vela tenha um desempenho muito melhor do
que era esperado para suicidar e o mesmo
em termos de estrutura é apesar de
algumas marcas do envelhecimento
cerebral
o seu cérebro estava muito mais
preservado zonas como hipocampo têm um
volume muito maior do que era esperado
para alguém com os cuidados e quando
olharam para as suas vidas condição
passos e branco os fios que conectam
diferentes zonas do cérebro
este estavam preservados como se fossem
os de uma pessoa jovem
o poeta como é no jornal escreveu o que
quis dizer com isto foi que as pessoas
quando fossem horários deus deveriam
pedir pela sua saúde física mas também
pela sua saúde espiritual
eu acho que é altura de invertermos esta
mensagem é porque é em corrupção que
causa um momento certo eu precisava
terminar com o sonho o sonho é quando
fomos fazer desporto não fossemos fazer
simplesmente porque ele está em forma
física mas sim porque - o nosso cérebro
e queremos que este se mantenha em tron
e porque não passarmos esta mensagem
para a sociedade
imagine uma altura em que as empresas
incentivam seus funcionários a irem
fazer expor porque querem que estes
mantêm os seus níveis de performance
imagino estudantes universitários ainda
da tutela exame para a semana mas é
dizerem os filhos vão fazer diz porque
eu quero que vocês 6200 ou idosos fazer
ginástica porque querem continuar a a
lembrar por muitos anos do que foi a sua
vida e para terminar
eu estava a terminar aqui como convida
todos vocês
ué da próxima vez que você se lembrar em
sair para uma corrida
ao saírem de votos tennis garden no
vosso fone colocarem uma música e serem
a correr é meio da corrida
por favor parem tirem uma self e na
altura de colocar em uma rede social é
só se isso é a step oeste é run for your
brain e aqui partir do tex porto que eu
quero lançar um movimento viral
eu quero que isto se torne global eu
quero todos juntos tenhamos e criamos um
movimento run for your brain obrigado